[Music]
good morning good morning well I wish it
was a good morning what did I ask you to
come into work today
what did I say was the one thing I said
to you come in as a but a boss right now
you look like a towel boy
I mean sunglasses around your neck badge
on their shorts on their who are you
give me the name badge
[Music]
stand out from the crowd you're the
owner I've had a really rough night and
serves my team get out of here get
changed and come back like an owner now
[ __ ] off ready honestly going up no no
no no no I'm not listening Gordon I'm
coming back like a boss I'm ready to
make this whole Fort Pierce community
prep Gordon get out of here seatbelt on
no doors no seatbelt oh my god up up be
back I'll be back I'll be ready
[Music]
Brian returned looking like an owner and
I'm hoping that translates into his role
as a boss let's go
Jarek quick step let's go it's time to
reveal to Brian and his staff the newly
renovated beachfront Inn and first of
all this is not the Spring Break hangout
that's gone wrong this is a proper
beachfront route sweet I love it it's
perfect but you've got a tangible asset
here that can help lift this business I
more importantly start making money
awesome Brian you need to get a grip of
this business
and you need to realize you know what's
at stake here I need to be convinced I
need to see you stepping up as a boss
Ben and Jerry we're relaunching that
restaurants nights so I'm gonna go
through with that menu Chum downstairs
get organized and start finding your way
let's go after observing dinner service
I saw the beachfront kitchen wasn't set
up to handle such a massive menu so I
redesigned a smaller menu that is easy
for Ben to execute okay guys it's all
menu let's run from the top appetizers
lobster mac and cheese done with the
correct posture been steamed clams again
great sharing for the table wings off
the smoker so stays nice and crisp and a
chicken cobb salad
entrees pan-seared scallops easy 3 says
ahi tuna fresh and then of course the my
a my its small its inviting and tonight
I've just been told that we've got the
mayor in for dinner one person we can
reach out to to send the message back in
the community this is it
dig in
that sauce is fabulous oh my god Wow